[Musique]
olivier roy le gérant de la serre
commence un manque ablement séjourné par
effectuer les livraisons à ses clients
en s'installant dans cette culture il ya
sept ans il s'était donné pour objectif
de privilégier le circuit court afin de
proposer des produits mur et goûteux
aujourd'hui il est heureux d'être
reconnus y compris dans de grandes
enseignes qui elles aussi ont décidé de
jouer le jeu pour répondre aux attentes
de leur clientèle
cocktail tomates à face et aux variétés
anciennes coeur de boeuf
ça fait plaisir de voir des clients qui
font l'effort de mettre en avant les
tomates et de faire un beau un beau
rayon pour montrer les tomates et en
plus ça correspond vraiment à ce que
l'ancien la demande c'est-à-dire ce que
les clients devront c'est à dire des
tomates se produit sans pesticides en
circuit court on est vraiment dans le
coup jusqu'au vol de gens sur le chemin
du retour
olivier est déjà dans le planning de la
journée qui comme d'habitude est fixé à
la minute près de retour dans le lieu de
production
olivier procède à l'installation d'un
des auxiliaires vivant de culture le
bourdon qui joue un rôle primordial
voilà des bourdons alors les bourdons
pour la pollinisation et après on a
le différents insectes pour la lutte
contre les parasites donc sa chance aux
tomates jeu principal paradis c'est la
mousse blanche
c'est en janvier que les 7500 pieds de
tomates qui feront entre 17500 à 20000
tiges sont plantés olivier nous explique
comment alors le procès de culture hors
sol c'est qu'on cultive là on plonge
dans un substrat inerte donc la
concurrence et de la fibre croco ensuite
on va mettre en place les les plantes
sur les trous qui sont prévues bailat et
les racines vont se développer dans le
dans la fibre et autres coûtent à la
pendant grèce sont en goutte-à-goutte
pouvait voir là les goûteurs qui sont
placés sur le pont tout ce qui est pas
récupéré utilisé par la plante c'est
récupérer ses deux rennais s est
réinjecté c'est récupérer et recycler à
peine six mois plus tard les tiges font
plusieurs mètres de haut
leur entretien et leur gestion réclame
un travail quotidien que nous verrons
demain